we're fighting against each other we're  all the same yeah and what we you know  what's going to help everything an alien  evasion from a different planet i agree  what i'm being real  you don't think so look at [ __ ]  independence day if we had to fight  another planet no one's gonna go whoa  yeah i'm a trump guy no one gives a [ __ ]  we have to get together yeah and fight  this thing and then we will find our  commonality which is humanity if that  happened that would be perfect that  wouldn't have to come together i don't  think so at all  well you think that it'll be split you  think aliens will be trump supporters  too and they'll have liberals as well  and then  probably yeah yeah i genuinely think  that make america great again make  america great again  even  [Laughter]  [Laughter]  the capital